Oh what is going on YouTube check it out
so before I go ahead and get into this
let me do a little quick talking about
something from my main man Steven
Spielberg who is a personal friend of
mine
even though he has returned my calls
this new TV show is called smash is all
about dreaming big and wanting to be a
star and we all know wanna be a star
college if the full pilot is exclusively
online so for all my little head Emmy
fans and it touches himself to the enemy
porn turn it off for one second so you
can go ahead and peep it first by
clicking the link below
that's right before anybody else and
before it airs on TV you can see it
online so take a second that today and
stop touching yourself so click the link
below and subscribe to that page and
make sure you leave a comment telling
them why you want to be a star anyway
today for this video I want to go ahead
and take the time and don't worry I'm
gonna show you guys a little something
funny at the end but real quick big ups
to a q-function for sending me some free
clothes ah which all things kind of
fresh right you don't say immediately
really anyways big shout to actor
function for hooking me up with the
shirts and of course the snapback thank
you very much you know burn burn but
back to the content so um a while back I
met somebody and uh like I said before I
know I don't hate on people having
dreams and wanting to be something and I
met a man who was an Asian rapper that
has a little tip when you want to be a
rapper just just be a rapper you don't
have to be an asian rapper a mexican
rapper a black rapper just be a rapper
so this is actually how I decided to
develop this character so I met this guy
and um he was an Asian guy and he wanted
to be a rapper he told me to straight up
now the problem was when I was talking
to him um I'm not sure if he knew he was
Asian
here's a sample of our conversation and
the reason why I was kind of confused
hey what's up man so you like the
hip-hop artists on one day new rare yeah
we're done I'm trying to get out there
and put out my music yeah it's gotta
rough out there huh he had to be honest
with you I'm kind of blessed it on my
brother out there in the industry you
know I'm saying a brother I fit and oh
wait hold on say you mean a brother a
black know you know you know um I
thought to myself I wonder what this guy
takes on a street time and this is what
I came up with it I call this
[Music]
honestly as a rapper like when I started
this [ __ ] it wasn't easy for me because
you know I grew up pretty broke I mean I
was poor [ __ ] I was like the only I was
like the only black dude in the
neighborhood black through the
neighborhood black through the
neighborhood but I was just gonna be
hustling you know my whole life but that
my homeboy maybe you heard of among
Jesus Christ not not the one up there
but the one on Vermont
this one kid I've been neighborhood
named a Tron you know day trying got it
all to my face saying like hey yo Dawg
like you don't even know what it's like
to be like really ghetto because like
unless you buy your [ __ ] at the Goodwill
store and you broke your [ __ ] at you on
welfare then you don't even know what
it's like well you get your [ __ ] from
the welfare [ __ ] my pants are made from
a rice bag you know in the front it said
home I you know so I to tell all the
black dudes in the neighborhood
it meant homey in Chinese what's up oh
my you don't saying dude let's be real
for a second like I haven't been picked
up as a rap artist it's because I'm
Asian because I'm a good rip yo I put
your baby in the face yo
I put your baby in the face every day
put your baby in the face yo
a bunch of baby in the face say I put
your baby in the face because you know
everybody wants to talk about you know
how they want to beat up that other a
block you know saying but he's a
grown-ass adult you know how case is
that I'm punching an infant if you're a
baby you know if you're a fetus if
you're a grandparent if you're pregnant
it doesn't matter yo
look yo I'm from the south side you from
the right side I don't care I'll put
your baby in the face a bunch of baby in
the face you write it up a bunch of baby
in your face cuz you pray it why do I
punch pregnant women it's because that's
like pre punching a baby in the face
before it comes out people don't really
understand you know my lifestyle like
the females and I'm kicking when they
don't really understand like what I go
what I tell them I'm a rapper though I
know I bet you go around and you sleep
with a lot of people that's not true
because a lot of women don't want to
sleep with me magic oh I just farted
lactose intolerant she never had that
you got day up
if you can't freestyle you can't be a
hip-hop artist period in the story I
think you suck man I am the best man yo
here's my mind-state your where's your
game plan every day I wake up punch a
baby in the face was like the only black
dude in the neighborhood
I see you move I'm checking your style
working your back like it's gone out of
style
j-just a little bit faster change just a
little now girl time to meet you too
let's mess around now only shows your
dance moves
rajesh OSHA decibels Melly show you
dance moves
Poppa girl working do get Guinea break
it down break it down oh no stop sorry I
turned off